[Music]  [Music]  j t z  [Music]  hi  hi  [Music]  nice  [Music]  time  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  time  [Music]  time  [Music]  um um  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  me mario  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  do the best you can  you're the best  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  okay  [Music]  [Music]  coffee house coffee house  [Music]  do  [Music]  do  [Music]  me  [Music]  uh  [Music]  me  [Music]  [Music]  jtbs can you do it one more time  [Music]  wow  [Music]  uh  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  tbs  [Music]  tip  [Music]  [Music]  do  [Music]  do  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  three  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  do  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you